devin larritt you son of a [ __ ] that's  freaking  what's the matter  mit got you pushing too many pencils all  right you got me  if i wanted to beat you what would i do  here if i can  make you come to me  this is the first step  always make me come to you  exactly it lets you use more muscles  against less muscles you target weakness  right you target my fingertips you get  to use more muscles so you see this  ridge  yeah  very important  the higher up this ridge is in my hand  the better  the more the pressure is in my fingers  as opposed to your fingers the better  right  yeah  wow the strongest arm i've ever felt in  my life  he's not even trying i'm very  specialized i'm a super specialized  athlete ladies and gentlemen devin  lehrer this is a huge honor  you